how does compound interest differ well
like I said it's still that same idea of
interest it's still 10 you same interest
in our same same principle so in fact
I'm going to be really really cheap and
this first part here all the way from
here to here is exactly the same sorry
that was cheap and you can't do that
okay but I want you to see right nothing
has changed if you have one year of
simple interest and what your compound
interest its compounding anyway nothing
is different there's still pain you six
percent it's still 2400 at this point
here at the start of the second year
everything is dozen if you've got a new
color there pick it up because now
things change this is where compound
interest becomes compound interests okay
what they do is remember how I said they
can consider each year as a new year a
new amount right so instead of working
out six percent of this they're going to
work out six percent of their than your
mouth the 2500 for so let's have a new
calculation here right this is going to
be 2544 and that's gonna add on its six
percent interest which I actually have
no idea what that is what was that it is
it 64
okay so you can see here because the
banknotes bigger they're going to pay
you more interest they're peaking
interest in fact on top of dangerous
that's this companion right from now on
everything is different compounded is
simple interest they sort of diverge
like this okay because now started third
year i'm adding on a different amount
there's that 2544 and i'm adding on this
new larger interest okay ah yeah we can
we can do this in our heads drinkin two
desserts soon come on help me out 696
and 64 cents ok so a bigger amount this
next bits going to be a little awkward
because we're going to have to do some
rounding but again this time the
interest is calculated on my new bigger
amount right so this is going to be i'm
going to have to write a little bit
smaller it's going to be the new bigger
amount and i'm going to get six percent
on that 0.06 ok this time because of the
awkwardness of the numbers of the
decimals were included i'm definitely
going after ground here ok so you go
reach you calculator and it's going to
give you more than two decimal places so
go ahead can you calculate that work out
what you get and we'll go to the nearest
cent
but I've been 61 okay since its point
798 it's clearly going to round up to 80
right okay so you can see now in almost
home actually I'm pretty much done all
the tricky things I've got on my three
interest calculations that have all been
done now I just need to combine it
together okay so I've got my 2696 and 64
cents plus my new rounded interest
amount 161 dollars and eighty cents and
my [ __ ] is going to tell me what 2001
thank you there we go let's put that
thing in the middle all right happy
times now the reason why I pointed out
before in asset with interests problem
right that there were two ways to do
this is because before they were just as
easy as each other like method one
method to both the same you can use
either but now that we get to this part
I think one of these methods is clearly
better for this question now that I've
done it by compound interest which do
you think would be good yeah yeah doing
the difference is clearly gonna be easy
because I'm comparing two numbers rather
adding this one and then this one and
then this one and of course the more
years the more advantage I got always be
comparing to start in the end rather
than add enough however many years of
compound interest I've got so my working
is going to say 2858 and 44 cents and
this one you can do in your heads what's
the difference four hundred and yeah and
44 cents done okay so you can see the
discrepancy there of course compound
interest is paid you more because their
patron interest on the interest as well
Roger just on the initial
okay so in the real world right on nu
bank account they're always going to
compound for you simple interest comes
out in a vanishingly small number of
kisses um however it still does actually
call it could simply calculate where the
simple interest in you stuff is how
you're asking yes so it depends on for
example if God forbid any of you have to
ever get to a loan shark to borrow some
money right they're not going to go
through and recalculate their interest
every single time they're just going to
say alright this is how much you're
borrowing for me I'm just gonna do a
simple calculations this is how much
interest will graph to pay me again okay
um I hope you never ever go to a loan
shark because they're not going to
charge you six teenagers you're going to
charge you like 20 okay but because it's
simple they're not like a big bank with
computers doing everything it's just a
guy in checkbook or whatever for his own
spreadsheet they're going to do a simple
way rather than